うふん
ちょ、危ない危ないホント
後、さんじゅう…えっ？５３ｋｍです。
遠いところから来られてますよね
あぁそうなんですよ～
ありがとうございます
あの、お疲れのところだと思いますけど
安全にご注意ください
ありがとうございます
おやすみなさ～い
おやすみなさいは心配されるだよ…
え、すごくない？まじで
やばいね
やばい
もうなんかね～満足だね景色で
割と
いや～
キレイだよー
なんかチャリこいでるばあちゃんが綺麗に見える….
ハイパー美顔補正かかってるんだよ
補正というかもうまやかしでしょ
待ってよｗｗｗ
妖魔だね妖魔
う～わ～いいなぁ～～
すごいよね
ねぇな、なんなのこのなんか
死ぬのかな？今日。
最終回でしょ完全にこれ
ロータリーなんちゃう
これRotaryね
下に降りれば
Senami Hot Spring₍瀬波温泉₎がある
温泉いいっすよね
温泉ありっすよね
村上市ですな
マジックで消えてた瀬波というところがここですな
今回の
ダーツの旅で
当たった場所でございやす
お葬式モードじゃないっスか…
まぁ着きましたね無事
来ました
あのかなり強行というか
死にそうなんですけど
まぁせっかく来たんで
参りましょう
はい
ウルールヤーヤーウルールイェー
んん～♡
んん～？♡
いや
ホモプレイやめてくださいよ…
あぁ～♡
町人を発見して
ひとまずこの町には何があるかをちょっと聞いてみようと思うよ
でも海水浴場だって
ひとまず海水浴場行ってみますか
そこで…
第1…
えもう、泳ごう、泳ごうぜ
泳ごう
おーお疲れーっす！
お疲れーっす
第1町人
映ってもいいですか？
あぁ全然大丈夫
あぁ本当ですか
いつも見てます
本当ですかありがとうございます
第1町人でございます
あ本当ですか？
おめでとうございます
ありがとうございまーす
村上市ってなんかこうすごい
これは勧めたいよみたいなってありますか？
えーっと...
日本酒？
やっぱり
あぁー
日本酒かー
シャケ！
シャケ
あぁシャケさっき言ってたね
ぜひ！
ありがとうございます
うわあああああ
いいっすねー
普通に泳ぎたい
ほら絶対そういうやつだと思った
二人でそれだけやってもらっても
あぁー鳴っちゃったよもおーー完全に
ｗｗｗ
あぁやばい
水着の女の人がいる
あそこ売ってんじゃね海パンとか
めっちゃ来たんだけど
うっしゃああ
しゃああああ
しゃあああ
うわああああ
んん濡れてる
相撲やんけｗｗ
ここらへんでおすすめのものとかってある？
おすすめっスかー
おすすめおすすめ
ここらへんでね
やっぱりあのテトラポッドがおすすめっス
ｗｗｗ
えあそこって登っていいの？
登っていいっスよ
あいいの？
おすすめされたからにはでもさ
テトラポッド？
行くしかないよねｗｗｗ
カシャ₍シャッター音₎
あざまーす！！
部活部活ｗｗ
じゃあみんな気を付けてね
ばいばい！
くそっ！
カウント！
カウントだ！
お前らァァァ！！
めっちゃケツに入ったんだけど
山形から来たの？
分かんないですここは
あそうなんだね
じゃあ気を付けてね～
そっか山形近いから山形の人たちも来てんだね
2000円買うよ
これ1800円
はいありがとうございます
ありがとうございます
おーお疲れっす
第
第...
じゅー...
なな！
村人でーす
あ町人でーす
あ17人目ですか
カシャカシャカシャカシャ₍シャッター音₎
めっちゃ連写
着替えてきます
ありがとうございます
溺れないように気を付けて
こんちは
こんちはー
今写真撮ってもらっていいですか
あぁいいよ
なんで皆こんなキャラ濃いの？
ｗｗキャラおおった₍？₎
すごいな
こんにちは
ティルルン♪₍電話切る音₎
ｗｗｗｗｗ
切っちゃったｗｗ
あ、走ったら痛くない
え？
アドレナリンじゃん
えでもさー歩くほうがさー...
とても多くの
町人が歓迎してくださって
はい。もう
ちょっと
プールに入れなかったっすね
海
海だよ
海っすねｗ
浮き輪だけ買いました僕は
もうちょっと村上の近くを回ってみようと思います
はいというわけで
次は
こちらのゆで卵を食べていこうと思います
温泉卵...
温泉卵を食べていこうと思います
しかも15分だって
熱いのかな
90°Cぐらいだから手入れちゃダメだよ。
熱いですか？
じゃんけんで負けたら入れようぜ！
ダメだよ。
あ！あ！あ！熱い！熱い！熱い！
平和だね～
平和かどうかは別として
YouTube映っていい人！
はーーい！！
わーいこっちだー！
じゃあ気を付けて！
ばいばーい！
はいというわけでダーツの旅
いや
黒マジックの旅ですね
新潟県の村上市に行ってきました
えーっとたくさんの方に声をかけていただいて
とても！嬉しかったです！
みなさんほんとにありがとうございました
えーっとですね今年の夏はね
こうちょっと
東京に行くことがほんとに多くて
なかなかこう
のんびりしたりすることができなかったんですけども
イベントとかあっても行くとしても多分
東京ぐらいしかないので
個人的になんですけど
もっといろんな地方の方に行けたらいいなと実は思っております
なんで今回適当に投げてたまたま新潟だったんでそちらに行ってきたんですけども
この企画がもし好評だったら
みんなが楽しんでくれたら
またね、時間があるときにぜひ
やってみようかなと思っております
すごいなんか景色もよくて
空気もおいしくて
人もいい人達ばっかりですごい
楽しい旅になりました
二回目もまた出来ればいいなと思っております
じゃあな！